l'histoire d'amour avec pourquoi elle
est si bon que ça tombe
j'ai pas encore couche avec lui à mon
avis ça va pas tarder c'est très bien
ici tu es parfait
mais bon je m'ennuie un peu
vous êtes né comme ça non j'ai eu un
accident de voiture quand j'avais 3 ans
pourquoi ça vous dérange non au
contraire
j'ai conçu le projet de vous donner mon
nom vient se pose est-ce que vous deviez
ma fille voilà où repose la femme que
j'ai le plus aimé le monde
maman bon alors donc il a passé quel
genre ton jugeant cela dure à cuire il
faut faire deux fils entrepôts bancaire
tes coups de bêche c'est une offre qui
ne doit pas refuser un contrat
maintenant j'aimerais bien un petit peu
voir le le météo cela peut avoir un
petit peu les petites culottes aussi
peut-être un peu de beurre
je vous écoute eléonore berthier que
vous connaissez bien je crois et sur ce
dvd je voulais ont bien hors jeu par la
compagnie
je pense que tu m'a pas fait venir ici
uniquement pour partager ton
petit-déjeuner ben non en effet la paire
de cus presque disparu
j'ai bien raison que ton jugé par
quelque chose
de faire deuxième bras évidemment et
tout son fric
le serbe a black widow fait ce qu'on
peut les bracelets comptant les rhumes